haha this is my mind burning me back
Brad Hart yo Brad hey dude man
keeping well can you hear me the
connection was pretty bad hmm
he's phoning me back
Brad Hart Brad Hart what's up man that's
alright that's alright how's the
property stuff go man oh yeah what have
you got anything else over the line yet
yeah yeah yeah but you mean you've been
putting the work in that's great man you
sent me 201 reasons now there was
someone else that also sent me a big
list as well but the second best was 200
so you were actually the number one you
with yours was the biggest list by one
yeah that's awesome so you did 201 and
it was literally too big it was too big
to send on YouTube so you said on my
facebook but what that means is that
means that we're gonna give you a three
thousand pound credit to do some
training with us which set which you
sounds like you need it because you've
been putting it out you've been putting
the hours in but you've been you have
not got deal yet
yeah yeah and even to a dip into a crash
course go yeah well here's what I'll say
get down to a crash course I'll get you
a three thousand pound credit sent over
to your email get down to a crash course
and then at the crash course we can have
a chat about how you want to how you
want to invest that that credit but I
tell you something Matt especially if
you come to a crash course that'll be
enough to get you your first deal
guaranteed and what we'll do is well
like I'd encourage you to vlog the
journey document it and you know put
yourself out there because you're gonna
get deal man you're gonna get a deal
very soon hang on man cost you well
course you up yeah sure
yeah there are some I'm taking a little
break over this summer but we've got
quite a lot coming up in like September
October sort of time so yeah for sure
man I'll get someone to put your name of
a credit and also a list list list all
the dates
yo awesome man I look forward to working
with you I look forward to seeing you
smash out the friggin party All Right
see you later Brad bye now boom so Fred
Brad is working hard needs the education
got no money oh how old he is me look
kind of young I've just gifted him a
three thousand pound credit to come on
some of our training programs and
literally I gave him that just for
commenting on YouTube videos because he
he listed he listed two hundred and one
reasons as to why he was going to
succeed that was the challenge I said
hey YouTube video comment below I want
you to list as many reasons as you can
as to why you will be successful because
most people come up with reasons why
that they won't be successful oh it's
hard it's the economy is not great and
any money I'm young I don't want to hear
that if you want to attract
to me and you want to get my attention I
don't want to hear all the reasons why
you can't because if you say you can't
it's true you can't it's absolutely true
people that say oh you can't do it it's
hard they're banging on right it is for
them
for me it's doable for me I bought my
first house when I was 17 years old so I
just said I want to hear all the reasons
why you can't because I'm attracted to
positivity so he listed 201 reasons as
to why he was going to be successful and
I was just like wow so cool him up he's
given to the crash course I'm gonna give
him a three thousand pound credit to do
some really advanced training with us
and the advanced training entails
guaranteed to work with you to do a deal
so I'm gonna be an amazing man I can't
wait to wear with that kid all right
see you real soon